Central America is in the midst of what
the world recognizes is a humanitarian
crisis criminal gangs are taking over
much of the region and a civilian was
more likely to be murdered in one of
these countries over the last several
years than to be killed in Iraq during
the height of the insurgency those gangs
are recruiting young teenagers and if
the teenager resists recruitment will
threaten endure even kill the teenager
or family members as a result many
teenagers and younger children are
choosing to leave their home countries
and seek asylum elsewhere in the region
they're going to Mexico to Costa Rica to
Agua and many of them are going to the
United States since October 1st of last
year 52,000 children unaccompanied by
adults have been apprehended by Border
Patrol and that's not counting the tens
of thousands of mothers who are bringing
their children into the United States
and to flee as well of course having so
many people come into the country
admittedly without papers is causing a
lot of controversy part of this is
because they've strained the existing
system which was built under the Bush
administration to deal with 6,000 to
8,000 kids coming across the border
alone every year not 52,000 but part of
it's because some would like the border
to be a force field to be able to
automatically refuse anyone who doesn't
have proper papers for being able to set
foot in the United States but there are
very good reasons that the border isn't
a force field US law has an established
process so that when someone comes
across the border and doesn't have
papers but fears for their life there
can be a way to determine if they're
eligible for asylum are another form of
humanitarian relief but that's the
system that's currently being
overwhelmed so the question facing the
United States right now is how far are
we willing to go in the name of
immigration enforcement without
undermining the humanitarian commitment
that if you fear persecution and you
escape to America we will try to find a
place for you
you